lil nas ex literally pulled out all the
stops with his old town road all-stars
performance at the 2020 Grammys on
Sunday bringing out BTS Diplo Maison
Ramsey and Billy Ray Cyrus to join him
on stage for one epic performance will
NAS X cap things off strumming his
guitar and singing old town road solo
while sitting in a room next to Kobe
Bryant's Jersey a nod to the late Lakers
star who died in a helicopter crash
Sunday morning do something cuz you know
it's unfortunate you know that this
happened on this day and then the stage
began to rotate revealing kpop band BTS
Diplo and Ramsey appeared next and
finally Billy Ray Cyrus but the
surprises didn't end there the crowd
totally lost it when NAS joined little
nas ex on stage it was a great
performance though thank you yeah I felt
the energy some things and go as planned
but we kept moving on
well Nozick spoke with et backstage
moments after rocking the Staples Center
alongside Billy Ray Cyrus who revealed
what exactly was going through their
minds it was emotional I don't know if
you know we all huddled and prayed
before we came out on stage and we all
pray for Coby Nate's family and the fans
and you know kinda like Elisha said
tonight this is on some ways a way to
honor him in his house and people coming
together and music and song and I felt
like there was a very kind and sweet
spirit in the house tonight and again
the tip of the hat to mr. Kobe Bryant
and what he's mad I don't know if you
noticed I even put a little special Kobe
on my guitar yeah I did that with my
just happen to have a silver sharpie in
there and I thought you know what I
don't put a little Kobe in here and it's
just a special I don't know what do you
the skin it's so bittersweet I wanna I
wanna be it felt great
I did feel first step down I was looking
at that big more arena that dome and I
was thinking how many times is that
crowd scream when that ball was switched
through the net you know with like a
half point second left food Lakers win
boom
[Music]